in the workplace a subset of men tend to
be serial sexual harassers so it's not
all men who do this it's not all bosses
who do this it's not all
men in positions of power who do this
it's a subset that engage in
multiple harassment
david boss welcome to the show thank you
hey
delighted to be here talking to you it's
happy book release day
yes it is uh it's it's hugely exciting
uh i've been getting a
ton of email people are tweeting about
it and
you know uh facebooking about it so
there's uh it's kind of an explosion on
social media so it's
it's very exciting and um you know
this is one of these things where this
book took me three years to write
and it represents more than 30 years of
research on and off not not continuous
research so
it is a true labor of love and so it's
nice to see this thing finally hatched
well deserved really really well
deserved i said to you before we started
i absolutely love this
um how would you characterize what
evolutionary psychology is
and why it's interesting and useful oh
boy
that's a big question um so that i will
try to be succinct on that but
evolutionary psychology is simply
psychology
uh look at through the lens of
evolutionary theory
and it basically is a um
uh adds important ingredients such as
functionality so whereas most
psychologists they don't look at
what is the they don't ask the question
what is the function of whatever
psychological mechanisms we have
uh they just say you know here's a
phenomenon cognitive dissonance or
obedience to authority or attribution
uh bias or evolutionary psychologists
ask well what is the evolve function
if any of the psychological mechanisms
we have
be they food preferences be they make
preferences
habitat preferences uh coalition
formation
friendship formation navigating kinships
navigating social hierarchies
and that functional lens uh just posing
that question
adds a layer of depth to our
understanding of psychology
that has been missing prior to an
evolutionary perspective
and so i think it it brings quite a lot
uh to the table and um i remember early
on in
in the field of evolutionary psychology
lita cosmetics a friend and one of the
founders of the field
told me that uh that there's no such
thing as a non-evolutionary psychology
and um at that time i was a little
skeptical but i've kind of come around
to her view
and in the sense that there's no other
causal process that we know about that
could have fashioned
whatever you whatever uh psychological
mechanisms we have
housed in our brain which of course is
an evolved organ
that's perfect one answer um this book
in the us is why men behave badly and in
the uk it's
bad men yes yeah that's right um i'll
tell you the
story about that first off why men
behave badly at all why not men and
women behave badly
uh well so first of all the book is
about sexual conflict
and the the co-evolution of conflict
between males and females
which goes back about 1.3 billion years
uh so sexual back to sexual reproduction
but i titled the book um
when men behave badly the hidden roots
of
sexual deception harassment and assault
for a very particular reason and that is
that i
when i started i uh thought i was going
to give equal treatment to men and women
and there's a sense in which i do so the
first five chapters or so
are equally uh bad stuff men do
and bad stuff women do so for example
deception and internet dating
uh is is a prime example but when you
get to the more
um high cost inflicting
uh behavior so intimate partner violence
stalking sexual coercion sexual
harassment sexual assault
the more extreme you get men tend to
have more of a monopoly on these
more dramatic and cost-inflicting
behaviors and so
uh over the the last four chapters of
the book i focus
more and more heavily on men as
perpetrators
and women uh women's co-evolved defenses
to prevent becoming a victim
of these uh of these horrendous uh
generically
forms of sexual violence um and
uh so um and so that's why i call when
men behave bad it's not it's not a book
about male bashing
uh because i specifically talk about
it's not all men
uh some men are more prone to these
forms of sexual violence than others and
we can get into that
in in detail and also when
men behave badly uh even men who do it
don't do it all the time i mean it's one
of the interesting things is you can
have
a man who's happily married has a loving
relationship with
his wife loving relationship with his
kids but then engages in some really bad
stuff on the side
and so the book tries to identify not
only which men do this
but what are the circumstances in which
men are most likely to do it
and so uh so anyway so that's the
the title for the u.s um the uk
uh what happened was here here's the
twist on that my my uk publisher told me
that
that a while back there was a uk sitcom
called
some it's called you can clarify for
it's called uh
uh men behaving badly yeah with martin
clunes
yes yeah and so it's a
sitcom and so my publisher my uk
publishers worried that people would
in the uk would have that association
some sort of biopic
of the men behaving badly sitcom
series written written by david buss
right
right right so uh so the hence the
the the change in title uh to to bad men
in the uk edition
but the content is identical and the
subtitle uh
the hidden roots of sexual deception
harassment assault
is identical so the book is identical
except for that um
main title in the uk cool yeah well at
least martin clunes isn't knocking on
your door asking for
royalty or usage or something like that
that would be a bad idea
so before we before we get into it what
do we need to know about sex differences
and male female mate preferences before
we can kind of
get into this discussion uh okay
let's uh yeah well that that's an
important topic because
sex differences in mating strategies and
in sexual psychology these are the root
causes of conflict between the sexes and
so
if you don't understand those you can't
understand
why men and women get into conflict and
this is in the context of um you know
this is kind of surprising to me
in broad in the broader field of
psychology
and that is that in psychology we have a
replication crisis which
you and your your listeners probably are
familiar with but
these sex differences are among the most
robust and replicable
findings in the entire field of
psychology while everyone else is having
a crisis
these are replicable and they're solid
and they're not trivial in in magnitude
either so
um so to get into just a few of them one
a key critical one is sex differences in
desire for sexual variety
and what i mean is the sex differences
and desire for a variety of sex partners
and so this is measured in many
different ways so
how many sex partners would you ideally
like to have over the next year
five years ten years um you know
men say uh well over the lifespan men
say about 18 sex partners would be about
right women say
four to five um many just say one
uh so uh sexual fantasy is uh studies of
sexual fantasy another indication so
how often do you have sexual fantasies
and about whom
do you have sexual fantasies and men
have sexual
tend to have sexual fantasies about a
wider variety of different
uh women uh if they're heterosexual and
and they also do more partner switching
during the course of a single sexual
fantasy episode so
uh so just just to give you one example
so in studies of sexual fantasy one man
said
my fantasy is i'm i'm the mayor of the
town so high status
and all the women down main street uh
have no clothes on
and every day i i get up and i stroll
down main street and decide
which woman i want to have sex with that
day uh
well it's like an inverse it's like an
inverse of the emperor has no clothes
it's like the towns the towns people
have no clothes and they're all female
right and they're all female uh so but
uh so that's just kind of an
illustration and
uh and then there's like how often you
think about sex
um how often do you fantasize about sex
with someone who just
a woman who just passes you on the
street um
if you've known a person for a
particular length of time and find them
attractive
how much the time would elapse before
you were willing to have sex with them
and for man that's close to zero you
know
one second um you know and women
typically need a lot more information
so there are many different sources of
evidence that all converge on this
key sex difference in desire for sexual
variety
and this is one of the things that
now of course one of the things that you
were kind enough to ask about
evolutionary psychology
one of the things that evolutionary
psychology does
is it distinguishes between underlying
psychology
and its expression and manifest behavior
and so
many men have these desires but they
don't just
act on them fortunately this would be
disastrous
if men just walked down the street and
had a desire for
sex with a woman and just like lunged
you know that would be
um total disaster and chaos uh and in
fact men
probably don't they they might act on
one out of a thousand of these
um sexual these forms of sexual ideation
uh uh and so a lot of men
and so even this includes men who are
married or men who
are already mated they might have sexual
attractions to women other than their
partner which they
often do and women do as well men just
have them more frequently
um but they may choose not to act on
them for a variety of
reasons that have to do with other
components of our evolved psychology
our concern with reputation uh our
concern with preserving our long-term
mateship
uh are our concern with not damaging um
our uh the social opinion in the eyes of
our family our peers our work colleagues
and so forth
um and so um and so that's why some
people
i think mistakenly divide up the world
into like
two causal forces like there are social
cultural forces
and then there are evolutionary forces
and what evolutionary psychology does is
it breaks down the
this false dichotomy as we call it
because our evolved psychology is
designed to be responsive to these
social and cultural conditions including
social norms and social reputation how
so
uh well we evolved in small groups
and the small groups had status
hierarchies
all groups have status hierarchies
informal or formal
and your position within the status
hierarchy
influences a whole raft of things like
who wants to be
your friend or ally and who's willing to
mate with you
so specifically for men more than women
well for both
so so i've studied status
and reputation things that lead to
increases and decreases in status and
reputation
both sexes are very very concerned about
reputation
including importantly in this context
sexual reputation
so um you know you have a reputation
as a cheater or as a
guy who uses women or as a guy who
cheats on his wife and that's going to
damage your reputation
which is why men who do act on their
married men or men in relationships who
do act on their sexual attractions to
other women
uh go to great effort to try to conceal
it you know so
um they try to have their cake and eat
it too so to speak so they want to
uh engage in the sexual activity but not
incur the social costs of that that
being known
so um yeah
so so anyway so that's a big sex
difference other
sex differences include sex differences
in mate preferences
so for example um
uh you know and and i demonstrated this
early on
quite a while ago in my study of 37
cultures that men
uh and women they share many made
preferences so both sexes want
partners who are intelligent kind
healthy
dependable and so forth no one wants a
mean stupid
disease-ridden partner but um
but there are some sex differences that
are universal and and men
tend to prioritize relative youth and
physical appearance physical
attractiveness and potential mates
women also value physical appearance and
this is one of the mistakes people make
they think that women don't care about
it
they care about it a lot they just don't
care about it as much
as men do men it's kind of like it it
overwhelms a lot of other things in the
male brain
the physical appearance and women tend
to prioritize
financial resources uh and and even more
important the personality
characteristics and social
characteristics
that lead to resources over time so
things like
is the man ambitious does he have drive
does he have
goals or is he you know sitting around
playing video games all day and
you know eating cheetos and drinking
beer uh
which is perfectly okay it's just that
women
like like men who have some uh some
drive
and and also social status so social
status as i mentioned that's a
a key correlative access to
reproductively relevant resources and so
um you know in all groups
resources are heavily concentrated
toward the top and then
and then get less and less as you move
toward the bottom of the bottom of the
barrel
social status wise and so those are some
sex differences in mate preferences
and they also can create conflict
between the sexes
so for example
violation of those things is a key cause
of divorce
in relationship so if the guy loses his
job
and this is topic maybe we'll get into a
little bit later
because during the pandemic there's been
a spike in the intimate partner of
violence
and one of the predictors of intimate
partner violence is guys who don't have
the benefits to provide women and so
they inflict costs on the woman in an
effort to try to keep her
uh to adjust the mate value discrepancy
yeah to adjust the
perceived mate value discrepancy so yeah
yeah so
so and this is a horrendous thing and
people might be very upset by this but i
i think there's good evidence that one
of the
the intimate partner of violence as
abhorrent as it is it actually has a
function
and the function is is it is a desperate
measure to hold on to a woman
who who wants to leave she wants to
defect from the relationship
uh or you know dip her toe in the water
with an infidelity to see if there might
be a better mate out there for
uh and so one of the things that these
violent guys do guys who are violent
toward their romantic partners
is they try to cut off their their
friendships they try to cut off their
kin ties their relationships with their
family their genetic relatives in an
effort to
strip them of bodyguards and this is
this is one of the things i talk about
in the book also that is women's
defenses against some of these
forms of male bad behavior is bodyguards
and bodyguards are absolutely critical
and so if the woman doesn't have
you know the father around the brother
the sisters the mother the the friends
male and female friends uh very
difficult for an abuser to abuse
someone if they if the woman has these
social allies
the bodyguards and so it's a critical
defense
which is why these abusive men try to
cut off those
uh bodyguards from from the woman so
um anyway i don't know quite how we got
onto that track i do a whole chapter
to intimate partner violence um
and i think it's a it's a really
important topic because
even in the most um like we we might
think about it
as uh you know horrendously worse in
some cultures than others and it is
uh but even in the most sexually
egalitarian cultures such as say the
scandinavian cultures
denmark sweden norway
the netherlands in rates of intimate
partner violence
are around 27 to 30 percent
in terms of lifetime incidents that is
the percentage of women who will
um experience intimate partner violence
at some point
uh in their lives so that as you're
talking about close to a third
of women who are subject to this so i
think it's a very important topic and
has been relatively neglected um it's
certainly
relatively neglected by it by
evolutionary psychologists
and that's why i devote a whole chapter
to it it's it's a form of
sexual violence in that even if
the the male doesn't rape his partner
which is another
topic that i that i talk about uh the
physical violence is basically an effort
to control her sexuality
and that's why i put it under the
umbrella of
sexual violence mitigating that sexual
access
is something that you talk about in
detail to do with mate guarding and
jealousy
and it seems to me like the
the effects that you're saying there
where you have an incredibly controlling
mostly usually male partner in a
relationship
it feels like that mate guarding turned
up to 11. we feel that the partner that
we're with is slipping away from us
we are concerned that you talk about um
[Music]
creating a small bridge back into the
dating pool rather than jumping in feet
first and getting cold i think you say
or you can create backup mates or you
can trade up in value there's all of
these different tactics that both men
and women use
um and it feels like the situation
you've just described there with the men
is when it gets
it gets turned right up to 11. some of
the things that i went through this book
the number of photos i've taken and sent
to my buddy rob henderson who we are
mutual friends with and he's asked
past guests on this the
i think one of the most interesting
insights that i took from your book
was the understanding of the over
perception and the under perception bias
i think it's a cure for so many problems
between men and women and how they don't
understand each other can you explain
that
yes uh yeah it's a great question and
and that's another
that's another important sex difference
so the uh
the kind of classic case is men and
women are interacting
woman smiles at the man or casually
touches his arm
or incidentally brushes up against him
and he infers
sexual interest on her part or romantic
interest
when it may not be there at all uh so uh
and this is a very robust finding that
uh
you know women often say well i was just
being friendly and in fact a smile is
one of those inherently
ambiguous cues you know it could signal
friendliness it could signal sexual
interest it could signal
uh nervousness if they should think the
guy is a creep
um and but men tend to over infer sexual
interest when it when it's not there
and and and we think that they do um
this is work that i initially developed
with marty hazelton
who's a former graduate student now a
professor at ucla
and um and what we argue is that it's an
adaptive bias
so there's a reason that men have this
and that is that missing out on sexual
opportunities
uh was extremely costly over
evolutionary time
uh and so men have this kind of over
perception bias to
err on the side of not missing out on
anything even if there are
it results in many false alarms you know
turns out another woman is not
interested
although we also argue and this is an
interesting thing that
um the fact that they think she's
interested
could actually be functional in
converting her
from initially uninterested to being
interested
uh so because it encourages behavior in
the mail which is more likely to signal
that he is interested which can cause
reciprocal interest from the female
yes that and uh confidence
so if if the man thinks she's interested
he's going to be more confident
and women value confidence and interpret
it as a sign of
a status even even if it's unwarranted
in reality but then but then manifests
from the mail
yeah but that's why like if if he thinks
uh oh she's not interested at all
and but i want to try to approach her
he's not going to be very
self-confident in that approach but if
he thinks oh she's genuinely interested
even if it's a false belief
he's going to rant he's going to feel
more confident in his approach toward
her
uh and then on the flip side we also
found this is work that i did with the
karen paraloo
another former student now a professor
and
what we we did a kind of like a speed
dating paradigm in our lab where we
brought men and women into the lab and
had them interact with each other and
then
afterwards say do you think this person
was sexually interested in you
how interested are you in them etc then
kind of rotate
and what we found is that women
underperceived
men's sexual interest that is women
thought now this guy's he's not
interested in me
when in fact the guys are saying yes i'm
very interested in her
uh and so they tended to underperceive
now this is an interesting thing this
was the first time that's ever been
documented
um and uh and we have a couple
hypotheses about why that's the case so
one is that men who are genuinely
sexually interested
try to eliminate um
expressing the sexual components of
their interest
uh because in fact it backfires so and
we we know this and there are
there are studies that have uh
documented this i did one in
in my lab as well where the more overtly
sexual the approach uh
the less the effective it is so
men in essence feign genuine interest
long-term interest um caring about what
she thinks
how she feels and so forth and just and
disguise any sexual interest at all
and so it may be that women are sort of
well he displayed no cues of sexual
interest so
um you know i don't think he's
interested the guys are saying yes
i've been thinking about her constantly
so
um so so but what what this does though
is this especially the male sexual over
perception bias results in sexual
conflict
because what it means is that guys are
hitting on women
and approaching women uh who are
genuinely not interested
and and and so that creates this a pro
problem
especially in the workplace but uh let's
talk about the workplace for example
uh in that he thinks he's in
she's interested in him so he approaches
her uh
and she is in a work context so she
might be a co-worker she might
the guy who's a person who might be her
boss
and so she has to deflect this sexual
attention
in a way that doesn't cause um
resentment on the part of the guy
because if it's if it's a co-worker or a
boss they can
do reputational damage to her they can
not give her promotions
they can undermine her in various ways
and so women do things like uh
uh oh i i i can't i can't go out with
you
uh i have a boyfriend uh or i can't go
out with you i'm i'm
vis i'm seeing my girlfriends for a
glass of wine tonight
and so they try to deflect it rather
than saying
look um i don't find you attractive at
all i'm not interested at all
please don't ever ask me again for
anything
they can't do that so they try to
basically uh
what uh sometimes is called a soft
rejection so
uh uh you know so but it puts women in
this
in this really difficult dilemma because
then sometimes the guys come back and
say uh
well get rid of your boyfriend or is
your boyfriend in town
now um you know if not let's uh let's go
out
or you're busy tonight how about uh next
wednesday
and so and so the and what it turns out
is with sexual harassment that
in the workplace a subset of men tend to
be
serial sexual harassers so it's not all
men who do this it's not all bosses who
do this it's not all
men in positions of power who do this
it's a subset
that engage in multiple harasses
harass harassment and so women often
know who these guys are
they'll sometimes tell a new female
worker like watch don't be
you know alone with this guy in the
supply room or whatever because
he's got wandering hands or uh whatever
so
uh but um but but again part of that is
the sexual over perception bias
can lead to or contribute to sexual
harassment
and that's why i think one of the key
things is we have to understand
at a deep level the underlying
sexual psychology of men and women how
they differ
in order to get the root causes of
sexual conflict
in order to eliminate or at best uh
uh eliminated best or minimize the
sexual conflicts that occur
uh because these are these are pervasive
forms of conflict
they uh they occur in many different
species
and they occur in all human cultures and
uh one of the things that uh if i could
jump in i'll stop and let you ask a
question here since i'm just kind of
rambling
is uh uh and i borrowed this uh quote i
kind of
it was reading steve pinker's book one
of his excellent books
and and he noted that sexual violence
against women
is perhaps the most widespread
human rights violation in the world and
the more i thought about it the more i
think that he's right and it's one of
the things i argue
in this book in that uh you what you
have is
these forms of sexual conflict they
transcend culture
they transcend uh transgender ethnicity
they transcend religious groups uh
it doesn't matter it's like a you could
say an equal opportunity
um destroyer uh if you will and so
uh and it affects half of the population
uh who are women
and it affects even more than that so it
affects
all those who are primary victims
primary victims of
sexual harassment assault
uh intimate partner violence partner
rape um
or stalking uh and uh in
addition it affects all those women who
have to engage in
defensive maneuvers to avoid becoming a
victim
so women sometimes they can't go out at
night
or they can't go out at night alone uh
or they have to take
various precautions and do things to
prevent becoming a victim so there's the
primary victims who are victims
and there's then there's the secondary
victims and then there are all the
people who
care deeply about the women who are
victims so
the the the partners the the fathers the
brothers the mothers the sisters the
female friends the male friends
uh who all care about this and then they
are
also traumatized by the their loved one
being sexually uh abused in one of these
ways
uh and so and so that's why i say the
most
widespread human rights violation is sec
is sexual violence toward women uh and
getting back to the evolutionary angle
on it so we we have um
is it basically violates freedom of
sexual
choice so we have uh at least in most
western cultures we have
uh freedom of speech we have freedom of
the press
we have freedom of uh peaceable assembly
we have these
freedoms that are granted to us but one
of the freedoms that i think should be
an
international human right is freedom of
sexual choice
um it's basically darwin 1871
uh who with his theory of sexual
selection where
he observed that throughout the animal
kingdom
uh females tended to be more
discriminating
or choosy or discerning about who they
had sex with who they mated with
and and that's why uh
women have adaptations to uh to avoid
that
bypassing female choice and adaptations
to be extremely upset
about attempts or or enactments of that
violation
um more upsetting than anything else uh
so
more upsetting than just purely physical
violence or
other other forms of of violence so
uh and so and so so this is something
that everybody should care about
and one of the goals of my book and and
this is perhaps
uh revealing of my arrogance or
or former arrogance i've throughout my
career i've always kind of fancied
myself as a
basic researcher like i only i'm pure
science i just study
human stuff yeah yeah not applying stuff
and then
but then uh i realized as i was writing
this book that this
is tremendously important information to
reducing sexual
violence and reducing the these
abhorrent
um costs that are inflicted on women and
so
uh so i've become more more applied and
i think that this information
is extremely useful in reducing
uh the harms that are inflicted on women
as a result
of male sexual psychology
so so anyway this is a long-winded uh
uh diatribe there but so i'll let me
pause and let you ask
a question or make a comment well i
think
so much of what you've gone through and
reading the book i have to confess and
this will be the same for a lot of men
that read it
it's uncomfortable as a man to read the
book
i think that you do a good job of easing
us in
and explaining the lay of the land with
what is to begin with
a relatively sort of balanced viewpoint
but as you say as we get towards the
more extreme ends of sexual violence
there simply isn't the research and
presumably aren't the
the um data to under pin the research
of women doing it to men there are
certain occurrences that happen but when
you get to the extreme ends when you get
to the rape when you get to the
the violence the intimate partner
violence and the stalking and stuff like
that it is disproportionately caused by
men
and it's very difficult as someone who
hasn't done that
to read it and think well this isn't me
and then
when we see um
overbearing and overstepping acts
coming from the women's empowerment
movement
that again blame men for toxic
masculinity and for the patriarchy being
it it is difficult to read and yet at
the same time
learning something like uh the
under perception and the over perception
bias
helps me to understand
not only the the dynamic generally of
the mating world
but it also helps me to understand other
men that aren't me
and myself so i think that's something
that is super important yes the
the insights that you have around
evolutionary psychology and how they
inform our
understanding of sexual conflict can
help women to
understand the risks to get past them if
it has occurred and to also deal with
them sort of during the process as well
if they are occurring
but i think it also helps men if people
understand if men
understand the fact that the woman is
probably less interested in you than she
seems
and that you to her seem less interested
than you seem
yes if you simply understand that there
is
so much more transparency around and
this is it's the same as learning a
cognitive
bias right it's like a mating bias it's
when you learn fundamental attribution
error you actually realize oh god
like that that's not necessarily the way
the world works he's not an [ __ ]
because he kept me up in traffic he
might just be late
like because i because i've done it
before um
but it is uncomfortable to read and i
think
that's a good practice for both men and
women to do
i enjoy delivering uncomfortable and
harsh truths on the show as much as
possible
and the reason is it gives us the
opportunity to observe what rises inside
of us
it's a mindfulness exercise right you
observe the emotion that occurs
as you hear something as you hear x
number of percent of
women have gone through sexual
harassment and you just want to scream
out as a man well yeah yeah but not me
that's not me and you go right we
weren't saying it was
right that's the that's the compulsion
that knee-jerk reaction because
a lot of most recent popular culture
there has been a lot of
finger pointing and given the stats that
makes sense
but also the um indignation
of a a huge swath of men
is also understandable but only with the
data and the understanding can we
actually
work out why that's the case yes i think
that's very
eloquently eloquently put and uh i mean
i i feel
very much the same way that um i mean i
don't to my knowledge
i haven't engaged in sexual harassment
harassment or sexual coercion
um uh but that's i think why i
titled the book when men behave badly
because as i said at the beginning it's
not
all men and so i think it's it's that's
an erroneous thing i think most men
um you know hold their desires
in check uh for a variety of reasons
that we that we talked about
but um but but but some men don't
and and uh and and it's the some men
that are really a a danger
not just to women but also to men in the
form that you
just alluded to which is that um
men get a bad rap uh and get blamed
for things sort of as a generic half of
the species
when that's not appropriate because uh
you know there there are men who would
never dream
of engaging for example in sexual
harassment or
intimate partner violence and um and
wouldn't do it even if you put him in
the most
conducive conditions for doing it that's
why some of these stable
personality characteristics uh are
critical
so in in the book for example i talk
about
uh the dark triad as being critical so
the dark triad is a constellation of
personality traits
that is uh narcissism uh
psychopathy and machiavellianism
narcissism being characterized a
hallmark is a sense of entitlement so
high narcissist guys uh they think that
they're great they think they're
entitled to more than their fair share
a bigger slice of the pie and and and so
they overestimate their
brilliance uh and attractiveness they
they think they're hot but they're not
um or at least they're not on average
more attractive than people lower on
narcissism
psychopathy is basically uh the empathy
circuit that most normal humans have is
severed
so these guys a dog gets run over by a
car and they laugh
you know they have no empathy for
animals or or other humans this will
actually have some
litmus tests for diagnosing some of
these things so
ask a guy how he feels about pets you
know
dogs or cats or or whatever watch it
watch him interact with them or watch
him interact with a
a child uh or watch how he treats
waiters and waitresses that's another
indication you know so
uh and um and then machiavellianism is
basically
people who pursue it a an exploitative
social strategy so these are people who
sometimes come off as cooperators and
then defect and cheat
they view other people as instruments or
pawns to be
manipulated and toyed with and moved
around
to a lot of like chess pieces so that
they can
obtain maximal benefit with least effort
and so it's this constellation this dark
triad
especially when you combine it with a
short term mating strategy
these guys are most likely to engage in
these bad forms of behavior like sexual
harassment
sexual coercion uh so um
so it is it is a subset of guys and as i
mentioned a subset of guys who are doing
the harassing
that are and this is why also i think
your point is a good one that
that men and women need to be aware of
these things
uh so there are these biases in
cross-sects mind reading
that if we understand them we can make
appropriate corrections
uh as you um most eloquently put it
why are women attracted to bad boys then
if you have this particular dark triad
of traits
why do women get attracted towards those
sort of things
yeah well well often uh well there are
two things
so one is that they do often have
characteristics that women
do find attractive inmates so these guys
are often
very self-confident okay if you're high
in narcissism
you think you're great and you think
everyone else should think you're great
and we as animals we interpret each
other at our own word
so to speak if you have high
self-confidence people think oh he must
have something going for him
and they're often risk-taking
and so women find guys who are willing
to who are brave in the face of danger
willing to take
risks physical risks or social risks
like uh telling a joke to an entire room
at a party
is a social risk but also physical risk
of driving motorcycles and
um you know parachute jumping ski
jumping
other things so these guys often have
traits that are
attractive to women but they're
especially attractive to younger
women why is that so it uh i i think
part of it is
um inexperience uh so these these guys
the high dark triad guys are disastrous
as long-term mates
but they can be sometimes very exciting
as short term mates
and sometimes you know younger women
engage in
they're the new in the mating market
they engage in experimentation
some sexual experimentation you know
mate switching and so forth
as they mature get some more experience
they want to settle down
typically not always but typically into
a long-term commitment ship
and these guys the high dark triad guys
can be very exciting as short-term mates
but
disastrous as long-term mates and
presumably the young women
will have found that out and you only
probably learn that lesson
a few times before you think yes there's
a there's a pattern occurring here
yes exactly why wouldn't that have
managed to become adaptive why isn't
that evolved
why why aren't all women sort of born
with that is it just that if it is a
short-term mating strategy then it
probably would be adaptive because he's
got excess fitness and excess reputation
therefore good genes sexy sun hypothesis
etc
yeah possibly it that i mean that's
that's one hypothesis
uh about it uh another is that we live
in a um
this is uh under the rubric of
evolutionary mismatches
we live in a pretty bizarre modern world
that is
very different from the world in which
we evolved so we
evolved in small groups where you would
have had
perhaps exposure to a few dozen
potential mates in your entire lifespan
and in the modern world we have access
to thousands or millions of potential
mates
in large cities or through internet
dating and so
and so these men also can engage in
behavior
and escape the reputational consequences
that would have occurred ancestrally so
in small group living everybody knows
everyone else
and you start doing bad stuff like
abusing women uh you're going to get a
reputation they're going to either kill
you or ostracize you from the from the
group
the modern environment we don't have
that so internet dating you're
meeting total strangers you don't know
who their social group is you don't know
what their
reputation is so with large urban
settings
and also geographic mobility uh
these guys can escape what formerly
would have been reputational damage
which would have been extremely costly
it's like a sexual snake oil salesman
moving proverbially moving from the
from town to town but it's just from
from girl to girl
yeah um i don't know if you're aware of
this
but there is a subsection of the
meninism world
or the uh the red pill movement world
for men's rights actively working to
create dark
triad traits so they they coach men
on how to develop the dark triad traits
it's something which is actually
aspirational i'll send you some articles
um once we're done
it is a fascinating corner of the
internet and
some of the stuff that these guys write
about these bloggers they're incredibly
proficient writers
very very erudite incredibly articulate
and some of the things that they talk
about are fantastic bits of advice for
men
and then some of the other parts talk
about how to cultivate this
entire series of how to cultivate your
your dark triads um personality um
because presumably from that side my
theory is that these are often men
who've either had no success with women
or have had success with women and then
been scorned and
their strategy
to now deal with the inevitable or
perceived inevitable pain of the dating
market
is to never care is to develop that lack
of empathy is to see people as tools to
be used so on and so forth so
it almost becomes a defensive strategy
that they can wrap around themselves
and then also to create this
um bravado this excess fitness which
doesn't actually signal excess fitness
this excess reputation which doesn't
actually signal excess reputation
and to use that because they know they
will get the success with the women from
that
plus they will inoculate themselves by
never caring by not having the empathy
they can never be hurt um and yeah it's
it's a wow that's that's frightening
terrifying
terrifying and yet for short-term mating
strategies
successful so you can imagine that in a
world where that was the
that was the outcome metric that a man
was optimizing for
that he might actually see what he was
doing is successful
and then see it as so successful that he
would coach other men on how to do it
and write a blog about it that was very
articulate so
yeah god i mean the that whole world is
especially from an evolutionary
psychology perspective it is
it is fascinating i want you to talk
about how men and women differ in their
motivations for stalking
because that is something i think
culturally especially among young people
we talk about
young girls sort of stalking their
partner's profiles seeing the
the other girls that he's liking and
stuff like that but you mean
something a little bit different here
you don't just mean kind of
uh distance mate guarding and kind of
checking up on jealousy
stuff you mean something a little bit
more intense yeah yeah so the what you
just described i would
call information gathering um
stalking when i talk about stalking i'm
really referring to
criminal stalking so it's a
it's it's really a fascinating
phenomenon
and so when it comes to criminal
stalking at least in the i'm not sure
what the uk laws but i think there
are there i think they're similar to the
u.s laws
where uh they're written in a way so it
has to be a pattern of conduct
uh such as following repeated phone
calls repeated uh
you know tracking of the of someone in a
in a way that instills fear in the
victim
and that instilling fear is a critical
part of the definition of
criminal stalking and so and so a woman
who's look who's
googling a guy she's interested in or uh
checking up on his facebook to see if
he's partying with other women
that's not criminal stalking uh because
the guy
presumably she's doing it he's not even
aware she's doing it covertly yeah
yeah so so i would separate
that activity from the criminal stalking
that instills fear in the victim
and when you get to criminal stalking
you have about eighty percent of the
perpetrators are
are men and about twenty percent uh are
women so men do tend to have a monopoly
but not exclusive so
uh there are women who do uh who do
stock i don't know if you ever saw the
movie uh fatal attraction yes uh with uh
michael douglas has a as a a brief of
fling with uh glenn close he's married
has a bring
bring a brief affair
with his co-worker and uh she just
proceeds to make his life
absolutely miserable like boils his pet
rabbit
and that does like it it's like a
disaster
there was a after that movie came i
think it's like this old this is 1989 i
think
after this came out there was like a a
uh
a rampant epidemic of sexual fidelity so
guys were
terrified of having a failure no way
they'd been scared straight
yeah hit the bed how funny
yeah well when you think i mean that's
the thing about infidelity is
one of the things the the the quote
benefits of it in terms of
sexual gratification and so forth are in
the here and now
the risks and the costs are they're
uncertain so they're probabilistic we
don't know if they'll occur or not and
they're somewhere in the distant future
uh and so but this movie made it very
uh salient what those costs can be
how funny what about
unwanted sexual attention why do men
do that is it just is it explained
heavily by the
the um differences in perceived interest
well there are a couple things there and
uh i i talk about that
in the uh in the chapter on sexual
coercion
so one is um that uh a phenomenon that
john maynard
talks about and did some cool lab work
on
called attentional adhesion so basically
he has like a computer screen
and what he says is an image is going to
come up and when that
when it and then somewhere else on the
screen there will be a
an x uh appearing either in one of the
four quadrants of the screen
when that x appears i want you to
disengage from the image you're watching
and then focus on that that x and so
basically the in a nutshell what he
found is that when men are
when the images of an attractive woman
men have trouble disengaging their
attention so
so they they do you know where is that
finally i'll disengage so he attentional
adhesion
so men have it and it's
linked to when that occurs it's linked
to a brain circuit known as the nucleus
accumbens
and the nucleus accumbens is one of the
pleasure centers of the brain
so men literally feel pleasure
from looking at attractive women and
there there have been songs written
about this you know i'm a girl watcher
uh et cetera et cetera so so men are
basically
uh they have evolved mechanisms to
attend
to physically attractive women and find
it very
rewarding to be uh to to look at
attractive women it's just
and now that leads that's also that's
become one of the background causal
conditions for things like
leering or oggling or you know
cat calling or you know staring i've
talked to
like for example one woman told me uh
that when
in her workplace she had to tell guys
they kept staring at her breasts
and she had to like say look look my
eyes are here
like she'll like bring their attention
away from her breasts
and and so you know men have these um
brain circuits that are attuned to these
features of women and and these are part
of the causal
uh the causal uh background for
leading to things you know you combine
that with a sexual over perception bias
desire for sexual variety um the
importance of physical appearance in
men's sexual arousal
uh you know where men see the woman
they're attracted to her they feel
pleasure looking at her
and they feel sexually aroused and they
can't imagine
that she doesn't feel the same way about
them uh and they don't
and this this actually gets to another
sex difference which is
absolutely fascinating and i talk about
it this in the book as well
that on average men find women more
attractive than women find men
uh and and this one one of the things
this leads to is
uh in the uh internet dating world
the top um 10 to 20 percent of
men get the overwhelming avalanche of
interest it's a perfect burrito isn't it
it's the top 20 of men for the top 80
of women the bottom 20 percent of men
for the bottom 20 at bottom 80
of women right right but but it is but
yeah exactly but
so it's it's fascinating so it plays out
in the internet dating world
but it's fascinating to think that you
know women just don't find men as
attractive on average as men
find women so uh and what that means is
that men will find a larger
array of women attractive and that
attraction is not reciprocated
and and then when it's not reciprocated
men do get uh resentful so um
i don't know if the there's uh this uh
old band that i
that i love that's part of my generation
but called the doors
you know jim morrison of the doors i
think some uh younger people know about
it but anyway
jim morrison has a lyric in one of these
songs which is uh
women seem wicked when you're unwanted
and it's kind of captures that um
resentment that men feel and and you're
alluding to this
i don't know if it's a movement or uh
yeah with meninism in men's rights yeah
yeah but there there's a related one
which is
the in cells uh in acronym for
involuntarily celibate
and these are men who are extremely
resentful
that um that they're attracted to women
they're sexually aroused by women and
that and that attraction is not
reciprocated by these women
and so they're involuntarily celibate
and
and we sometimes it shows up in extreme
cases like the
the shooter out at santa barbara the
isla vista shooter where
he wrote in his uh i guess i don't know
was a facebooker in his diary that said
he's
on this day i'm tired i'm gonna punish
all these people
you know because i'm tired of being you
know sexually rejected
ever since i hit adolescence i've wanted
women and they don't want me and
and so the insults they even have terms
for
guys that women are attracted to they
call them chads
and and then and then the the women they
call uh stacy's
you know the the you know why stacy i
don't know
uh but you know origin
of incel actually came from a female
so the person that first posted about it
was a female college student
in a blog attraction i didn't know that
i tracked this back last year again i'll
find you i'll find you the article for
that
so let's let's just kind of try and
recap that that men
undertaking unwanted sexual attention
thing right so
we have a proclivity
men men have a proclivity a particular
brain circuit which encourages them to
look at women that are attractive or
look at them in a sexual manner
which is i guess what would be classed
as objectifying now
in some sort of a way sexualizing
objectifying them so that's hardwired
into us
not only that but we get a reward for it
we get some sense of pleasure which is
there to encourage us to do it must have
been evolutionary adaptive
uh again it makes sense if there is the
potential if there's a one percent
chance of having sex with this woman
you'd better be on your on on your
haunches sort of on alert to do it
just in case on top of that we have
the overperception bias we think that
she is probably as interested as us
and i i mean
that explains so much that explains so
much especially
it explains why men act that way
and it should make women i mean i might
be biased but that makes me feel
compassion
toward the men as well as the women
because it makes me think you were at
the mercy of your programming here
yeah well desperately trying to wrangle
your nature
under control to be societally
acceptable
yes and you combine that with
the desire for sexual variety that was
the one uh
and a high sex drive what that means is
and and with respect to
uh feeling sorry for men i think there's
a way in which that's correct in that
men are saddled with these desires
that can never be met you know that that
are more women than you
that you want to have sex with than you
can have sex with yeah yeah and now i
guess you know if you were
a small percentage of men who were at
the the top of the heap so i don't know
if you're a famous rock star a famous
athlete you know they they do
uh and and often fulfill their desire
for
you know hundreds and hundreds of sex
partners but for most men
uh for the vast majority of men they
can't they're they're
uh they live these lives of proverbial
quiet desperation
you know where they have desires that
will never be met and they just have to
live with them
what are the differences in the
motivations for stranger rape and
acquaintance rape
difference in in motivations um
well uh yeah strange rape so so first
uh zeibo as you know a whole chapter two
chapters devoted to
rape or sexual assault one uh dealing
with the psychology of the perpetrator
the perpetrators and one dealing with
psychology of the victims of
the defenses that women have to prevent
becoming
a victim or fend off the assault or deal
with the aftermath
um and uh and this surprises some people
but
the vast majority of rapes are not
stranger rapes they're actually a
minority
ten fifteen percent uh or so uh
most rapes occur uh their their date
rapes or acquaintance rapes
uh and even uh partner rapes so
and and this is an interesting
historical
fact that marital rape used to be an
incoherent concept
that that is people if you say marital
rape the husband raped his wife they say
what are you
what are you talking about that can't
occur uh and
at least in the united states in most
western cultures that there is now
a law that uh so the law used to mean
if you raped a stranger that was
criminal activity if you raped
your part your romantic partner or your
your spouse that was not
criminal activity uh and so
uh now who created these laws it's
interesting that
these laws are a reflection of male
sexual psychology well
this is my partner i am entitled to
sexual access to her
uh whenever i whenever i want uh and
um so uh
so so you combine those with
acquaintance rapes and date rapes
and then things like uh i don't know
it's the stereotype but it has some
some truth fraternity parties on college
campuses
where the guys spike spike the drinks um
typically with high uh amounts of
alcohol so that you don't taste the
alcohol and
you know this kind of sweet um punch
that that that they serve and um
and one of the stereotypes
is that the guys who rape are these kind
of
ugly low mate value drooling
strangers who are jumping out of the
woman from a dark alley
and that's not true and one of the
things i talk about in the book is
so this is one it's kind of a cool
example
of an evolutionary hypothesis that i
think
has been largely falsified or at least
is not
correct in its original form and that's
what's called the make deprivation
hypothesis that is that it's uh the
loser males basically who can
these in cells that we talked about
earlier on yeah yeah who can't attract a
woman through
normal means resort to rape as a last
strategy and it turns out that
uh that it's almost the reverse that is
the the best predictors
of who does the raping is guys who are
actually successful
they have a short-term mating strategy
high sex drive high desire for sexual
variety
and they can get away with it so in the
modern environment
the the guys that have made the news uh
bill cosby harvey weinstein uh
even the governor of new york andrew
cuomo
less more sexual harassment than rape on
his side
uh jeffrey epstein be another one these
guys are
often very wealthy very high in social
status
but they're able to get away with it
because of their
power because of their wealth and they
can
pay off victims so for example the you
know
well and this occurs in deviating a
little bit from your exact question
uh sexual harassment that occurred on uh
fox news for example by bill o'reilly
and roger ailes and everything
it turned out these guys were able to
pay off the women with large monetary
settlements that had non-disclosure
agreements uh so it was guys who are the
at the low end of the
resource and status totem pole they they
can't get away with it
as much and so if you talk about people
who have been
convicted of rape uh that yes
they do fall at the lower end of the
totem pole
but that's not a reflection of the guys
who actually
do it um and get away with it what that
suggests
is that most men have a desire
to do it and only those who have the
faculty to be able to get away with it
with limited costs
or um sufficiently motivated actually
end up
committing it and this is something that
you talk about here
in in the book about are all men
potential rapists
right right and and i i think that the
the answer is the answer to that
is unknown but it's probably no i think
that
you know to do the experiment what you'd
have to do is
put men in the a low-cost situation
where there would be zero penalties for
engaging in a rape and the closest
proximity we have to that would be a
warfare context where you're in a group
that has just
killed all the males in this group and
there's this group of helpless females
with no defenders
uh and rape and warfare of course is is
very common but but not all men do it
and i think that there is there are men
uh and we don't know what percentage
who would never even under the most
quote optimal circumstances would never
engage in rape um
and and i think it's you know your
uh earlier reflection that you know
these you know when they say
all men are doing these things you say
well no that
i'm not doing those things and i i think
so i think that the answer is no i think
that
uh the the all men we can't say
definitively
because obviously we can't do the study
where we put men in these situations
okay we're going to slaughter all the
bodyguards of these women and
put you in this no-cost situation we
obviously can't run experiments like
that
but um you know if i were
in the armed services as a psychologist
doing studies
i would look at well what are the
characteristics of the men who
do rape in those circumstances and
characteristics of men who do not
and i think again the dark triad is
probably going to play a big
role uh in which men do and which men do
not
how do you think men can protect
themselves
from enacting sexual assault of all
types
uh i i think deep knowledge of our
evolved sexual psychology is key and
and we we covered some of these bases
earlier i think that
it it really we really have to
understand
that we do have the sexual over
perception bias and i'll tell you a very
brief story
um on that uh that caused me to correct
my my uh sexual reception bias to the
degree that i can't so some of these
things are more easily correctable than
others so
so i was uh i teach a course in uh
human mating strategies psychology of
human mating
and i was this was a a while back and i
was teaching about the sexual over
perception bias so this is we're talking
a long time ago um and as i was taught
describing the sexual overperception
bias there was a woman in the class
who's like kind of lit up like a light
bulb and i thought something i
just said really struck a nerve with her
and sure enough class ended she comes up
to me afterwards she's a very attractive
woman
very kind of a smiley disposition and
she said that
this perfectly explained why uh
her relationship with her boyfriend
ended and it ended because
they would go to parties they would go
to bars together she and her boyfriend
and other guys would just be hitting up
on her right and left
and so she was attractive but also she
was very smiley very friendly
and the boyfriend was like constantly
jealous and so
he couldn't take it and she couldn't
take it and here's the thing
so i had just been teaching a sexual
overperception bias
i thought she was trying to hit on me
[Laughter]
so it was like i i still with that
knowledge
had difficulty turning it off now of
course you know then i i go back to my
office and then i have the metacognition
that no
you know is my sexual perception bias
yeah uh but um but i think i think that
knowledge about these things has to help
to reduce
conflict between the sexes because if
we're unaware like for example
uh there's also this movement now what i
call sex difference denialism
and there's this worry that somehow if
we admit that there are any
fundamentally evolved sex differences
then this will be disastrous and result
in discrimination against women
i think the opposite is true i think
recognizing
these fundamental sex differences in our
sexual psychology
is critical to not harming women so i
think the sex difference denialism
actually harms women
because it makes us ignorant to the
causal processes that are
resulting in sexual violence what's your
opinion of the term toxic masculinity as
it's used in
2021 well i think there
i mean masculinity there are
you know uh toxic elements to it uh so
uh you know i think that if it's used
precisely to describe those bad elements
like what i would call dark triad type
elements
then it's perfectly appropriate but i
don't think that it captures
all elements of masculinity so at least
you know now versions of masculinity
have changed
across cultures and over time but some
are quite noble
you know uh sacrificing uh protecting
the woman
shining bravery in the face of danger um
you know uh and historically even a man
you know
providing and protecting his family
providing for
and protecting his families his wife's
children so i think there are
uh you know you don't want to take a
broad brushstroke of the word
toxic and you know slap it on all things
that are
male related but you also don't want to
neuter
that and this is one of the the
interesting things that we see
the the front brain stuff the things
that we can rationalize and cerebrally
come up with an
understanding for those are the ones
that we can tweet about we can have
social movements about
but when it comes to the more base stuff
when it comes to things like attraction
there is not a chance in hell that the
um person that misuses toxic masculinity
and wants to tear down the way that men
are constructed
would would not look to date a male if
it was a female or even a male
who wasn't higher in mate value than
them and i was able to get resources
you don't want to date a shorter man a
man that's less educated or a man that's
got less money than you
so what we can do in the front of the
brain
and what our biology and our psychology
still wants to enact or in this sort of
constant battle
and i think that you're right what we
need to do is only through complete
transparency
can we get those two things to align and
say okay
this is how we are this is why we act
through the things that we do
and um good lord if this
if this book is not a very uncomfortable
way to arrive at that
david i've been looking forward to this
for a very long time i'm very very glad
that you've joined me
uh either bad men or when men behaving
badly
will be available on amazon everybody
that has been interested in this
conversation should go and check out
it's a fantastic book i know it's your
first
return to solo authoring in a decade
maybe over a decade something like that
yeah yeah so i've revised some of my
previous
books uh but this is my first new new
book my first new news
uh soul authored book yeah i'm very
happy to get back to it and
this is i said this is a labor a labor
of love and i really do hope that it
helps i hope that that it helps men i
hope that it helps women
and i hope that it helps to reduce
conflict between the sexes because
we have to understand each other's
sexual psychology and that applies to
both
women and men so i think that's that's
the key to reducing sexual conflict
i love it and davidbus.com to look at
research papers and check out the rest
of your stuff
yeah yeah just my name so davidbus.com
will take you right to my website
that'll have links to my books links to
my uh scientific articles
which can be downloaded for free uh and
links to
other things so yeah davidbus.com just
go and get this go and get men when men
behaving badly behave badly when men
behave badly go and get that get
whatever it is it's in the show notes
below go and buy it david thank you so
much for today
thank you chris been great chatting with
you it's been a lot of fun
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace